joining me now from kiev is roman
skillarov who managed to flee mario paul
with his mother and his brother roman
thank you so much for talking to us how
did you manage to get out of mario paul
and what was that journey like
thank you for this uh interview uh yes
um
[Music]
it was hard to leave that city because
all my family
tried to stay there
and i
try to convince them to move immediately
and 24 february
in the morning
and
they tried to stay there
and
after
i convinced them we just
pack our luggage and
move with hope that
in few days we come back but
as we see
it's unpossible and we lost connection
with the or
all our friends and relatives
my grandmother still there
so you have no news out of mario paul at
the moment
um
no anything
i just can see some twitter and news
about what's happening there from
uh photography and video
and a few days ago i saw us
um
army of azov battalion uh posting
twitter video with the house which is
burned
and it that's house was my home
i was saw your house
burnt
yes
i'm so sorry have you seen um
the pictures today of that maternity
hospital that was targeted
yes about
are you hear me
yes go ahead roman you're frozen but we
can yeah there you go we can hear you go
ahead yes um i saw news yesterday about
this hospital
number three
as i know
i was shocked because it was in its
center of city and by the way i was born
in this city and this hospital
yes
and so where you are now in kiev what is
the situation there um
yes um i was not i'm not exactly in
center of kiev it was closest city a
small town
pitiaslov it's a small town near kiev
because we're hearing that the mayor of
kiev says that two million people have
fled the capital
yes yes
there is a lot of people
also run away from kiev and trying to
escape but uh
it's hard
it's hard because it's blocked
many ways and the roads
so
what are you what are you going to do
roman you you can't leave the the
country can you because yes
so what are you going to do
for a moment i have to help my mom and
my small brother
to keep them safe and
i have to care of them
and
we are just to try to
help each other and support each other
and uh hide because every day we hear in
air sirens
and
it's scary
i hope in a few weeks or days it will
finish and we can live our life as
before
what will you do if the russians come
into kiev roman
i cannot imagine
it's
we feel that if they come into us they
just will kill us it's horrible
have you ever thought that you may have
to fight
[Music]
i say don't have military experience
[Music]
best way for us is
support and
be a volunteers
in a way what we can do
so as
i can help my mom and small brother
this is best way instead to fight if i
don't have experience with this
and
i prefer to piss away
how old is your brother
if you don't mind me asking
yeah it's 19 years but he also don't
have
this experience and my mom
is
old woman so i have to care of her
do you think that you will move out to
the west and try and go further
away from the russian advance
yes i think about this also
but
at the moment i don't have where to stay
at there and we are prayed
because road is
a dangerous place
i saw many videos that in a road
these terrorists just kill people
during this
movement
are you are you with other people who
also escaped mario paul are you entirely
on your own there um no only three of us
um
my mom my brother and me
we escaped the first day 24 february
um
many of uh other people
decided to stay because they was
thinking that it's uh nothing serious
but in the front morning i hear the
it was explosion close and
bullets
it was a
scary situation and i decided the best
way to
run away
roman thank you so much and best of luck
to you
thank you